well let's switch over to talk about
eggs and I'm gonna ask you some of the
same questions and also to draw some
contrast you already been doing that to
some extent so the first is just to say
tell us about the kind of women who
become egg donors so again in my
interviews with egg donors I found sort
of two groups of women so the younger
college students who are interested in
being donors to make money in order to
pay for their education there was also a
not insignificant number of young
mothers who were in their late 20s
they'd had children of their own they
might be staying at home and being an
egg donor allowed them to contribute to
somebody else having the joy that they
had experienced with their own children
as well as to make some money without
having to work a nine-to-five job and
what are the criteria for being an egg
donor you kind of suggested earlier that
they're not quite as stringent as being
a sperm donor like sperm donors egg
donors are providing a bodily substance
and so they're subject to some of the
same screening mechanism so they have to
provide the three generations of family
health history they're doing genetic
testing they're doing the contagious
disease testing they're doing blood
testing but the difference is in
addition to the height and education
requirement that I talked about before
one of the expectations that isn't
really written down anywhere is that
women donate for the right reasons and
so for women who call an egg agency and
say well I'm really interested in laying
my eggs for some cash that's a quote
from one of the people I interviewed
those women would not be allowed to
continue because they're not doing it
for the right reasons and again we have
these expectations of femininity where
women are going to be helpful sort of
naturally caring wanting to help people
have children that are suffusing the
expectations for donors in this area so
those motivational expectations really
exist for egg donors and they don't at
all for sperm donors so it sounds like
there's a real gender difference between
sperm donation as employment make some
quick cash egg donation as help build a
family do it for the right reasons very
deontological is that kind of what you
found in your research yes absolutely
and it's not only something that affects
how the egg agencies and sperm banks
operate I mean it's how they're
recruiting people it's how they're
screening them it then affects the
donors experiences so women walk away
from egg donation with this narrative of
I help somebody
and I made $5,000 or $10,000 and so
women can feel good about what they've
done and helped make this contribution
and in contrast the sperm donors I
interviewed felt as if they had been
milked for a resource they could provide
they felt a little bit alienated and
objectified as sperm donors and so
that's the last thing I expected having
started this research you know
interested in these gender comparisons
to walk away from this research thinking
wow you know sperm donors get kind of a
bum deal they too are helping people
create families they too are making a
huge difference but nobody's writing
them thank-you notes or giving them
gifts or telling them how wonderful they
are and it's interesting because a
little bit of a flip of the typical
gender narrative right and that the men
are being treated as a piece of meat as
kind of objects rather than partners
whereas the women seem to have on the
one hand it flips a gendered narrative
on the other I guess it reiterates a
gendered narrative about caregiver and
warmth and altruism versus work right
exactly
say a little bit more about the payment
and the recruitment so you'll hear in
many courses and bioethics they'll show
you an ad run in the Harvard Crimson or
another newspaper at a college campus
saying this tall this SAT score this
ethnicity and then promising a very high
amount of money it would seem for egg
donation is that the way it typically
works how are they paid how are they
recruited so these advertisements that
you're mentioning really get a lot of
attention but the standard issue first
time egg donor who's going through an
agency can expect to make five or ten
thousand dollars for that donation so
this is something that is changing right
now so there was just a lawsuit brought
by egg donors against the American
Society for Reproductive Medicine for
price fixing for setting these
expectations for what a good amount of
money is for egg donation so this will
be interesting to see as we move forward
in the next couple years how that
affects the prices of egg donation so
this case was settled actually it was an
antitrust case and the solution was to
remove the recommendation from the
American Society for Reproductive
Medicine to pay between five thousand
and ten thousand dollars so as you say
now
without this recommendation in place
it's possible prices in the market will
fluctuate or change by the typical egg
donors you say the first time through
can expect in the u.s. to make between
5,000 and 10,000 dollars
and where do a a brokers and you've used
that term maybe we should ask about that
these the term brokers or agencies with
eggs we typically don't use that term
for sperm what are these entities and
how do they recruit women how do they
find women so this again is an
interesting historically infused
difference in the language that's used
so the idea that there are banks of
sperm and sperm donors are paid Keira
Swanson has written a really interesting
book about the history of that bank
language and in contrast egg agencies
really grew out of fertility agencies
the idea of adoption agencies and so
that language of agency versus bank
again sociologically is coming from the
industry and I think that we need to pay
attention to it and a agencies think of
themselves as matching recipients and
donors in the same way that adoption
agencies match recipients and donors
cephalic agencies also grew out of
surrogacy firms originally and so
there's sort of a historical timeline
through which these technologies emerged
and built on each other didn't the thing
that's interesting to me is that when
egg donation started they didn't look to
sperm donation as a model they looked to
surrogacy or they look to adoption and
again I think that's because we think of
eggs and sperm as different kinds of
bodily goods and that's interesting
because you know the market too has
supply meet demand but in a very
impersonal sort of way whereas the
agency seems to be a much more artisanal
kind of way of matching people all right
well and that ties in also with the
technology itself so egg donors still
typically do provide fresh donations and
so in egg agencies you're matching one
woman with one recipient they're cycling
together in order for the egg donor to
produce eggs right at the time the
recipient is ready to receive them and
that's very different from the logistics
of sperm banks where the donors coming
in and producing a bunch of samples
which then get frozen and then sold to a
lot of different clients over time and
so it still is a one-to-one relationship
for the most part in egg donation
although that too is changing as egg
freezing becomes possible people have
now started up egg banks and I think
that technological shift is going to be
interesting to follow to see if egg
banks start looking more like sperm
banks and one of the questions will be
whether the
current gendered setup of the work
follows from gender stereotypes as it
follow from the technology right we have
in some ways a bit of a natural
experiment on this question yeah there
will be a dissertation to be written is
how many egg donations does a typical
egg donor do so you've told us sperm
donation is kind of a relatively middle
or long term service employment regular
thing I take it egg donation works very
differently well again here I don't have
any statistics to offer you because we
don't have any way of knowing how many
egg donors there are how often they
donate how many children are born egg
agencies typically limit women to five
or six cycles because they are concerned
about the long-term effects of young
women undergoing fertility medications
in order to produce eggs for the
recipient however they've really pulled
that number out of the sky we have zero
longitudinal studies about the long-term
effects of women who undergo egg
production either to be a donor or for
their own in vitro fertilization cycles
or now for those who are freezing their
eggs for later and I think this is an
absolutely crucial point about this
market and one of the things that I
think is the biggest scandal about this
market is that we have been doing IVF
since 1978 there has been plenty of time
to run those studies and we have some
retrospective data asking women who
later developed problems were you an egg
donor did you do IVF but we haven't
tracked women over time which is the
gold standard of medical studies so I
actually think that women who undergo
egg donation women who choose to be egg
donors can't actually give informed
consent because we don't have the risk
information to give them and I think
it's in a really important thing to
think about especially as we hear
stories about egg freezing be this
technological solution to women's
biological clock these are risky medical
interventions that we don't actually
know all the risks of one thing that's
interesting here is separate IVF right
going through all this to produce your
own offspring versus but you might think
of as a medical procedure okay there are
risks but there's also benefits you'll
have a child versus doing this with egg
freezing where it's about a potential
future use you may never need versus
doing it for third-party donation where
you are subjecting yourself
to these unknown risks for the benefit
of another person and for financial
benefit to yourself and whether we
should think about those categories
differently right well and I think we
have an ethic and a law in this country
that women have reproductive choice they
have reproductive agency so this is not
an area that I would say there should be
a governmental decision about who should
be allowed to do these things or not
however I think that we need to have a
much more direct conversation about what
we know and what we don't know about the
risks of reproductive technology and
here the risk profile is radically
different on the egg side and the sperm
sauce is rightly yes so this is one of
the questions that I always get about
the study is can you really compare
sperm donors with egg donors and
certainly sperm donors are going in
there masturbating in a small room
they're handing that sample over to a
lab tech they don't really encounter any
direct physical risks of that procedure
in contrast to egg donors who are taking
on these unknown medical risks and
injecting their bodies with fertility
medications and going through outpatient
surgery all of which does carry risk at
the same time I think that you know if
taking those biological technological
differences into account we can still
look at the language around these
different markets and see the
expectations that are placed on the
donors so just a thought experiment we
could think of sperm donation as a gift
from one man to another in which men are
making this huge difference in helping
people have families it's
technologically possible to pair one egg
donor with a number of different
recipients who are cycling at the same
time but that's not how we organize
those markets and so the gender
differences that we see across egg
donation and sperm donation really
aren't reducible to technology or
biology absolutely we have to take
biological differences into account but
they don't provide an explanation for
why these markets look different and one
thing that's interesting is the law and
regulation of these areas tends to treat
the two more symmetrical as you've said
several times very little law and
reproductive technology in the United
States one of the things that makes just
an outlier but also a market for inbound
medical tourism but what law we do have
for the most part for example allowing
or forbidding compensation treats the
two markets symmetrically but I hear
from
there's actually big differences in the
markets that might have a role in how we
ought to think about regulating them is
that kind of right well you know this is
a point at which maybe I differ from the
legal scholars in the room on
reproductive technology so I think that
when people hear about these markets or
they hear that we don't know about egg
donors and sperm donors one of the
things I think it's really important for
us to have as some basic data about the
size of this market how many people are
participating what are their experiences
I am much more reluctant to get involved
in the business of regulating this
market and that's because I think about
the really long and terrible history of
government involvement in reproductive
decision-making and I think that we have
to proceed extremely cautiously we don't
have a good history of this nobody has a
good history of government regulations
of reproduction and as in France you can
actually write discrimination into the
regulations whenever you think about
sort of using democratic processes to do
that so it's one of the places where I
have not come to a firm position on this
do we need more data yes do I want to go
out and start regulating these I get
much more nervous when we talk about
that fair enough